what is harder to solve
vision or language visual intelligence
or linguistic intelligence
so i'm going to say computer vision is
harder my reason for this is basically
that
uh language of course has a big
structure to it because we
developed it whereas vision is something
that is common in a lot of
animals everyone is able to get by a lot
of these animals
on earth are actually able to get by
without language and
a lot of these animals we also deem to
be intelligent so clearly intelligence
does have like a visual component to it
and yes of course in the case of humans
it of course also has a linguistic
component
but it means that there is something far
more fundamental about vision than there
is about language
and i'm sorry to anyone who disagrees
but yes this is what i feel
so that's being a little bit reflected
in um
the challenges that have to do with the
the progress of self-supervised learning
would you say
or is that just the peculiar accidents
of the progress of the ai community that
we focused on link or we discovered
self-attention
and transformers in the context of
language first
so like the self-supervised learning
success was actually
for vision has not much to do with the
transformers part i would say it's
actually been independent a little bit
i think it's just that the signal was a
little bit different for
uh vision than there was for like nlp
and probably nlp
yeah folks discovered it before so for
vision the main success has basically
been this like crops so far like taking
different crops of images
whereas for nlp it was this masking
thing but also the level of success is
still much higher for language
it has so that has a lot to do with i
mean
i can get into a lot of details for this
particular question let's go for it okay
so the first thing is language is very
structured so you are going to produce a
distribution over a finite vocabulary
english has a finite number of words
it's actually not that large
and you need to produce basically when
you're doing this masking thing all you
need to do is basically tell me which
one of these like 50 000 words it is
yeah that's it now for vision let's
imagine doing the same thing
okay we're basically going to blank out
a particular part of the image and we
ask the network or this neural network
to predict
what is present in this missing patch
it's combinatorially large
right you have 256 pixel values if
you're even producing basically a 7
cross 7 or 14 cross 14 like
window of pixels at each of these 169 or
each of these 49 locations you have 256
values to predict
yeah and so it's really really large and
very quickly
the kind of like prediction problems
that we're setting up are going to be
extremely like
intractable for us and so the thing is
for nlp it has been really successful
because we are very good at predicting
like doing this like
distribution over a finite set and the
problem is when this
set becomes really large we are going to
become really really bad at making these
predictions
and solving basically this particular
set of problems
so if you were to do it exactly in this
same way as nlp for vision
there is very limited success the way
stuff is working right now
is actually not by predicting these
masks it's basically by saying that you
take these two like crops from the image
you get a feature representation from it
and just saying that these two features
so they're like vectors just saying that
the distance between these vectors
should be small
and so it's a very different way of
learning
from the visual signal than there is
from nlp okay the other reason is the
distributional hypothesis that we talked
about for nlp right
so a word given its context basic the
context actually supplies a lot of
meaning to the word
now because there are just finite number
finite number of words and there is
a finite way in like which we compose
them of course
and the same thing holds for pixels but
in language there's a lot of structure
right so i always say
whatever the dash jumped over the fence
for example
there are lots of these sentences that
you'll get and from this you can
actually look at
this particular sentence might occur in
a lot of different contexts as well this
exact same sentence might occur in a
different context
so the sheep jumped over the fence the
cat jumped over the fence the dog jumped
over the fence
so you immediately get a lot of these
words which are
because this particular token itself has
so much meaning you get a lot of these
tokens or these words which are actually
going to have a
have sort of this related meaning across
given this context
whereas for vision it's much harder
because just by like pure like the way
we capture images
lighting can be different um there might
be like different noise in the sensor
so the thing is you're capturing a
physical phenomenon and then you're
basically
going through a very complicated
pipeline of like image processing and
then you're translating that into
some kind of like digital signal whereas
with language
you write it down and you transfer it to
a digital signal almost like it's a
lossless like transfer
and each of these tokens are very very
well defined there could be a little bit
of an argument
there because language as written down
is a projection of thought
this is one of the open questions is
if you perfectly can solve language
are you getting close to being able to
solve you know
easily with flying colors past the
touring test kind of thing
right so that's it's similar uh
but different than uh the computer
vision problem is in the 2d
plane is a projection with
three-dimensional world
so perhaps there are similar uh uh
similar problems there maybe this i mean
i think what i'm saying is nlp is not
easy of course don't get me wrong like
abstract thought expressed in knowledge
or knowledge basically expressed in
language
is really hard to understand right i
mean we've been communicating with
language for so long and it's
it is of course a very complicated
concept the thing is
uh at least getting like some somewhat
reasonable um
like being able to solve some kind of
reasonable tasks with language
i would say slightly easier than it is
with computer vision yeah i would say
yeah so that that's what i'll put i
would say getting impressive
performance on language is uh
easier that i feel like for both
language and computer vision there's
going to be this
wall of like that you like uh
this hump you have to overcome to
achieve superhuman level performance
or human level performance and i feel
like for language it's that wall is
farther away
so you can get pretty nice you can you
can do a lot of tricks
you can show really impressive
performance you can even fool people
that you're tweeting or you're right
blog post writing or your
question answering is has intelligence
behind it
but to truly demonstrate understanding
of dialogue of continuous
long-form dialogue that would require
perhaps
big breakthroughs in the same way in
computer vision i think the big
breakthroughs
need to happen earlier to to achieve uh
impressive performance
you